[Musik]
wir vertrauen darauf dass all das gute
das josi gewirkt hat in simbabwe und in
der schweiz 100 feldfrucht bringt dafür
danken wir dir durch jesus christus der
uns bruder ist und herr armen
[Musik]
ernst willi ist der generaloberer der
immer sehr missionare begeistert war er
nicht als er 2013 in dieses leitungsamt
gewählt worden war
denn nur ungern verließ er sein
geliebtes sambia wo er 26 jahre gelebt
und gewirkt hatte schmerzlich war die
rückkehr in die schweiz
er verlor einiges an gewicht und
lebenslust und noch heute träumt er
gelegentlich afrikanischen kommt auch
kommt jetzt bin ich zum teil da wir mit
kinderlachen und dass ich jetzt alles
weg ist so ruhig und tische sowie das
auf das heim und bleibt also viel mist
ich natürlich denke ich habe wenn ich
jetzt darf ich komme werde ich umgebe
vor jungen erlebt und so wieder zurück
aber er will er hat er müsse sagen ich
war jetzt nicht nostalgisch sie den
notruf jetzt nur sich wurde dass ich mit
dem zug kommen wo mir zuruft 30 versuche
das so gut wie möglich machen mit
teilnehmer begrenzt sein
conny und sonntag union nicht das
missionshaus bethlehem liegt zwischen
vierwaldstättersee auf historisch
durchtränkten boden bei immensee gleich
ausgangs der hohlen gasse wo wilhelm
tell den tyrannen gessler ermordet haben
soll
die schweizerische missionsgesellschaft
peter helm kurz smp genannt war im jahre
1921 gegründet worden und geht die in
den folgenden jahrzehnten zum größten
katholischen mission unternehmen der
schweiz
bruder alois arnold musiziert auf der
dachterrasse für einige mitbrüder 27
jahre wirkte er in kolumbien als
schreiner auf einer missionsstation bis
der bürgerkrieg zu grausam wurde und er
das land verlassen musste auch sein
leben böte stoff für ein dickes buch
manchmal magath heraus erzählen manchmal
lässt er bloß das ärgerlich sprechen
doch meist schweigt er aus der
innerschweiz sorgen die missionare in
die entlegensten ärmsten winkel der erde
als zählen ritter und entwicklungshelfer
christliche haudegen und ja auch
verwegene abenteurer die patres und
brüder viele davon eigenwillige
persönlichkeiten schufen damit ein
bewegtes stück schweizer weltgeschichte
die erste nehmen sie ab ion ihre waren
1924 nach china gereist
von dort aus der mandschurei konnten die
missionare schon bald gutes katholisches
gedeihen in die heimat melden
doch nach 1950 wurde der kommunismus zur
einzigen erlaubten religion ist der neue
gott die katholischen missionare wurden
aus china verträgen die illmenseer
hatten jedoch längst andere weltgegenden
entdeckt wo haydn auf ihrer bekehrung
warteten in asien lateinamerika und vor
allem in afrika und ein schwerpunkt land
der schweizer missionare wurde süd
rhodesien das heutige und viel anderes
mehr
so lernen die jungen schwarzen schon
früh wie man ein feld gebaut und der
garten pflegt besonders aber werden sie
durch das beispiel des museums bruders
von jahr zu jahr mehr begreifen dass der
christ eine andere einstellung zur
arbeit hat als der reide heute müssen
diese bilder und kommentare irritieren
paternalistisch ja überheblich wirken
sie doch der auftritt der weißen männer
entsprach dem damaligen kolonialen geist
und dies mit heutige norden zu
kritisieren erschiene etwas billig
[Musik]
elisabeth vetter steigt mit ernst will
die in den keller wo die geschichte der
missionare in kisten lagert die
historikerin ordnet für das luzerner
staatsarchiv die hinterlassenschaft der
missionsgesellschaft
[Musik]
ja doch ich doch eigentlich ist sie ja
ja
in japan ist das zu wenig
die hand nicht in kontakt kommen und
jetzt
und die hat sich genau an und bezeichnet
und ich habe wenn ich versuche mich
selber ziehen denn die sind
stark sie sind mit denen und anständiger
als vorboten und alles was ich tue ist
sie also das glück seid dann bin ich
wollte gute nachricht sie da muss ich
ein schlechter laufen können sie also
schlachte bänder oder jude law zu den
fotos gepostet
das hätte ich locker wie so sehr kann
dritt ernst will die der generalobere
ist unterwegs nach afrika wo es einige
dinge zu regeln liegt
das regional haus der ebenseer in drive
und ihm zehn papiere missionswerke haben
die schweizer schon vor jahren der
einheimischen kirche übergeben was ihnen
blieb ist diese anlage ein alters
refugium im afrikanischen busch rund 200
kilometer südlich der hauptstadt harare
gelegen
einst in der blütezeit der smb in den
60er jahren wirkten 140 schweizer
missionare in diesem land dies sind wohl
die letzte nehmen sehr in simbabwe ein
dutzend betagte herren bruder toni
schenker zum beispiel der jungen
afrikanern das leder handwerk ball
brachte
oder bruder johann in ohren der 1951
nach rhodesien kam wo sich der bauernbub
wie sheen in den helden eines
abenteuerfilms verwandelte heute ist der
weitgehend verstummt die bildliche
missionare ausschließlich weiße männer
sind es denn die immense hatten stets
darauf verzichtet in den missionen
ländern einheimische für ihre
gesellschaft zu rekrutieren um die junge
lokale kirche nicht zu konkurrenzieren
und so hat nun das ende heute ist eine
aussprache angesagt denn die pensionäre
in simbabwe hadern mit ihrem schicksal
sie haben angefangen junge afrikaner als
angehende immer sehr missionare
anzuwerben ohne die zentrale in der
schweiz darüber ins bild zu setzen
ernst wie sie ist aus der schweiz
angereist zusammen mit dem generalrat
dem vierköpfigen leitungsgremium der smb
sie wollen die rettungsaktion stoppen
denn sie kommt jahrzehnte zu spät
die größte bedanken sind einfach mehr
sind überall die missionale sind alle im
pensionsalter und die habe ich noch vorn
er zieht her wo kolonial system welches
im büro des exils die hand komplett an
die emissions- erfahrung im hintergrund
und wie waren die junge lützow
priestertum vorbereitet oder eine
million hätte in kraft treten
man ist überein gekommen dass
rekrutierungs projekt zu stoppen
doch nicht alle können sich damit
abfinden
es war der vierte good news und mehrere
tote sondern nach wer gut wie das ist
schon gelegt dass wir auch nicht weil
sogar und erlebt als sehr lang und wo
der marke war die sache eigentlich
passiert sind unter woche sind womit sie
welt negativ oder verboten
ich bitte wirklich nicht einfach dazu
wenn ja wie er dahin müssen wir mehr
sterben muss
das dass sie vom mittwoch
[Musik]
jeden morgen noch vor tagesanbruch macht
sich peter gabriel in stoff auf seinen
weg der in eine halbe stunde durch den
busch führt
der walliser ist 84 jahre alt seit über
50 jahren in afrika und fast blind
doch den weg findet er auch so er kennt
hier jeden stein
[Musik]
sein tägliches ziel ist das einstige
mission spital
er besucht kranke oft sterbende um mit
ihnen zu beten ihnen trost zu spenden
[Musik]
gabriel in steckt bietet in der schule
sprache jener bantusprache die von den
menschen hier gesprochen werden
[Musik]
ich kann noch so viele fehler machen so
vielseitig und machen mehr wird alles
für ci versorgung nur weil du dich mit
der kranken absicht ich kranken und
sterbenden
aber da hatte ich sehe den dem tritt 15
wir machen viele fehler oder man
besonders am anfang die kirche die
gebrechen und
und während er wichtige epoche
schnellbleiche und dann geschah vor
was ist das schwierigste zeit auf fuß zu
fassen afrika schwierig sprache die
sprache absolut nichts die medien sprach
um den hammer dazu dadurch nach
studierte und dann wird man reden und
reden und fehler machen und das macht
nix
er probierte und ist schön gesprochen
schöne sprache viel viel später in der
sprache englische sprache als in selbst
im innern weil es sehr leicht
das ist die nummer zwei sprach ja nun
mal riesig
nach nunmehr zweisprachig echte wahl ist
weil es der leiter regionale jesu nehmen
wie panama city wunderbar man avatar
timocom vera wang gewann
da kam mir
ich finde aber von dem wieder hier und
jetzt zu spät dass er mehrere
katholische wallis macht das leben für
strassen zu vermehren und das kann ich
dutzend mal im takt
[Musik]
wenn es sie acht mal nach vorne und
alles geht kaputt
alles was die pflanzer tg kaputt wird
von der sonne verbrennt um den kurs
erregern unterbestand mit dem blechdach
und denn der stabilen oder leicht zum
beispiel wende in der serie darum sich
hier haben wir blechdach und videos
prediger und den seit der herrgott jetzt
herumlief predigt brille und händlern
nutzen
und da verstehst du das wort mehr da
sind
jetzt vorwärts mit gottesdiensten und
wird geblockt und macht das ist noch
viel schöner als jetzt die schönemoor
bestimmt das gebäude da dass ich das
sanatorium tb und das hätte man lena 50
60 dass der berühmte hathaway hat das
geboten
und darin sind ich damals petri hunderte
die 150 patient ob sie und die hände
jeden tag zweimal fleisch sprache und
darum hätte mission war das skifahren
mit seinen museen dich die große mission
fahren griff und ihn und die hand und
rief ihr stück fährt mit gurt in der
woche um die tat führte und das modell
der ideologie hunger sterben und das ist
schön wenn man den ich als anbieter
lichter oder das sterbe ich wieder eine
einfache sache
die ligue 1 immer noch die schwarze
menschen die stärkung der deutsche
schnitt war aber noch haben in de das
ist schön der dankbarkeit nachher ich
schöne sache erfüllte im moment sehen
wir die dankbar stellen und die
besonders die anklage wurde die den
diese schnittstelle zwischen leben und
tod das ist die seelsorgerische
spezialität von gabriel im stiftungs
weise 3000 afrikaner habe er schon
beerdigt sagt er
der mit seinem missionars leben im
reinen ist
die einstige missionsstation von brief
von team
[Musik]
hier ließen die bethlehem missionare
ihrer vision eines besseren lebens
wirklichkeit werden
die schweizer errichteten schulen über
270 im ganzen land sie bauten spitäler
straßen staudämme all dieser werke sind
mittlerweile an die einheimischen
übergeben worden
an die lokalen kirchgemeinden die
ebenfalls von den immensen aufgebaut
worden sind
es ist abend geworden und vor der kirche
warten die missionare auf den bischof
sie sollen ihm bei einer messe
assistieren in einer plastiktüte trägt
ernst will die die arbeitskleidung mit
sich die liturgische reizwäsche wie er
schon mal scherzt auch nach jahrzehnten
in afrika ging den schweizern der sinn
für pünktlichkeit nicht verloren und
damit wächst der unmut über die
ungültigkeit des bischofs doch dann wird
alles gut
und es kann ein gottesdienst beginnen
der mit afrikanischen gesängen und
rhythmen der römischen vorlage entrückt
ist
[Musik]
das mag ich beliebt
zusammen wpa2 bistümer die schweizer in
zehn pappe aufgebaut mit heute 100
afrikanischen priestern und noch viel
mehr nonnen dieser kirche wird weiter
gedeihen auch nach dem abgang der
missionare bischof union gar nie ist als
gast der eben sehr über nacht geblieben
beim frühstück geht es auch um die
ungewisse zukunft der missionare in
simbach und der bischof hat dazu eine
klare meinung ich persönlich würde es
sehr begrüßen wenn die missionare
einheimische junge männer rekrutieren
würden und dann diese den geist von
bethlehem weitergeben könnten
doch dazu ist es jetzt wohl zu spät
bruder john burkhardt ist 89 jahre alt
er wuchs als uneheliches kind in
thurgauer kloster fischingen auf 1953
kam er als missionar den langen weg
übers meer und durch den suez kanal nach
rhodesien ein gelernter schlosser
doch er weiß auch brot zu backen und
würste herzustellen
so hat er mit gebrauchten schweizer
gerätschaften in dre von thien diese
bäckerei und metzgerei eingerichtet denn
in mir klar dass ich eine vision sesseli
verbessere mit verschiedenen
fleischsorten und wie immer mehr fleisch
kochen und fallend wurst dings ist
hauptaktionär braucht an und meinte
weiter wir nicht schaffen zwischen
lehrling sie und die anderen arbeiter
sie und jetzt jetzt sind mir da wird
sich nur noch alles kaputt dass ich habe
dass das trüge im ganzen sektor
auf diesen topf war bruder john
besonders stolz was da alles drin
purzelte alles sehr wahrscheinlich
landjäger fleisch alles haben wir
gemacht alles da durch fabrikations sie
es ist es ist die maschine die der blitz
und der schädel und knochen durch nieder
ihr sportlicher betritt wenn man das
wird eine traurige nur mit ruhig und und
sogar vorsicht sogar ja wir es besser
machen
nein richtig vermittelt wie der mister
heiko erschwert das auto blieb während
zum beispiel kriterien durchgefallen
wenn es verrückt worden sind das hat der
verwerter sowas machen ja er wird dann
wirst erich bei den hightech ich habe
desto war jetzt der demokrat mit es nun
mit karl dennis nur schlimmer
bei der sache sind etwas passiert geld
ja ich hab ich bis los
was ist durch sagt dass das so ist
korruption stelle erreicht dass das ist
halt das übertrumpfen ihre so dass
krupps land in sie habe
[Musik]
bruder john beim aufbau der mission
das war vor 60 jahren
[Musik]
und stets packte er zuvorderst an in der
hoffnung seine arbeitszeit beispiel
genug damit auch die afrikaner sich
schweizerische tugenden an eignen würden
als busch pilot brachte bruder john
medizinische hilfe in die entlegensten
dörfer
[Musik]
doch es ist nicht alles so gekommen wie
er sich schon burkhardt erhofft hatte
das war einmal die blühende mission
swarm es also nur noch 140 stück 4200
vibrierende richtig alle verkauft oder
gestohlen wurden und daher ist das zeige
dass ich fordere jeden morgen 40 höher
und am airbus jetzt guck mal 13 meter
die milchschwemme hergestellt
jedermann hat jedermann hat genügend
milch und und und es mit milch
aufgehoben
aber alle die richtige sie haben nicht
alle in der werkstatt gemacht mit einer
bürste für fahne
der 89-jährige ist verärgert darüber wie
das vieh vernachlässigt wird deshalb ist
fressen wollen wir sie erinnert sich ist
nämlich eine zulage
ich bin nicht ihr freunde hat das nix
denn die wiese finden so das motto der
stadt langsam
erstmalig war
[Musik]
fast eine ewigkeit leben die männer
schon hier gibt es das handy heimlich
starb
[Gelächter]
wenn ich mich in dieser männer
hineinversetzen
dann habe ich das gefühl dass für diese
älteren priester und brüder
dieser ort zur neuen heimat geworden ist
sie fühlen sich hier zu hause und sie
möchten hier bleiben bis zum ende ihrer
tage denn sie haben sich an dieses land
gewöhnt an die art der menschen hier in
simbabwe wenn sie jeweils in die schweiz
zurückkehren fühlen sie sich dort wie
ein fisch auf dem trockenen
und doch an ihrem alterssitz haben sich
die missionare mit viel schweiz umgeben
wenig erinnert daran dass man sich
mitten im afrikanischen busch befindet
bis man einen blick in die küche wird wo
gute geister dafür sorgen dass es den
betagten weißen männern an nichts fehlt
[Musik]
der friedhof hinter dem regional haus
hat sich in den letzten jahren gefühlt
schweizer namen zieren die einfachen
kreuze vor wenigen tagen wurde hermann
stoffel ein walliser auch er in die
afrikanische erde gelegt ein nadelwald
soll den friedhof bäume aus der schweiz
ordentlich in reih und glied gepflanzt
so geht der letzte weg durch ein
stückchen heimatlichen gpx waldes auf
den friedhof wo das ende sichtbar wird
packt gabriel im schlepp so etwas wie
ein heiliger zorn unverständnis darüber
dass der missionars nachwuchs
ausgeblieben ist
liga ersetzt
die wissen gar nicht wie schön das
missionarische ruhen auch drei männer
die in der bevölkerung als märtyrer
verehrt werden
missionare die in den wirren des
befreiungskriege gewaltsam zu tode kamen
kilian esser war ein schulkollege von
ernst will die aus rudolfstetten er
wurde 1980 erschossen
um hochtechnische dass ich glaubte
unabhängigkeit und da so komisch erzählt
die kitas erlebnisse also ab der laut
grabner von abhängigkeiten
so hält man sich lieber am mission nach
sich heraus dass alle fragen können die
zu hoch und sind auch andere
das ist beinahe vom missionskreis das
mit bitte lücke blieb solange das
möglich ist um das vielleicht auch die
süße das mögliche entsteht und sogar
ausbauen betont martin holenstein wurde
1979 in einem hinterhalt getötet
abgemacht dass ihrem
neujahrsgottesdienst am ort und ist er
so durch als dorfpfarrer quartett nach
1966 eskalierte im damaligen rhodesien
der konflikt zwischen der weißen
regierung und der schwarzen mehrheit die
sich gegen unterdrückung und verachtung
auf lehnt die ebenseer hatten damals
klar partei
griffin für die schwarze bevölkerung
weshalb sie vom weißen regime als
kommunisten beschimpft worden
einer der rebellenführer war robert
mugabe die schweizer missionare gehören
zu unseren besten freunden
sie arbeiten bestens mit uns zusammen
in den reichen gegenden wo ihre kirchen
sind haben sie unsere kämpfer mit
nahrung versorgt
sie haben ihnen kleider gegeben sie
haben sie medizinisch betreut
sie haben uns moralisch bei unserem
kampf für gerechtigkeit unterstützt
doch es gab auch rebellen welche die
priester als agenten des kolonial
systems verdächtigten und so waren die
schweizer missionare zwischen die
fronten geraten der freiheits krieg der
mit einem sieg der schwarzen
nationalisten endete forderte gegen
30.000 menschen leben die meisten davon
schwarze robert mugabe der in jungen
jahren als lehrer für die immer sehr
gearbeitet hatte regiert in basel seit
der unabhängigkeit
doch der damalige hoffnungsträger
wandelte sich zum diktator der nicht
mehr von der macht lassen konnte und
sein land wirtschaftlich und politisch
in den abgrund steuerte alois graf blieb
während des befreiungs krieges auf seine
mission posten mitten im kampfgebiet dem
immer sehr war klar für welche seite er
sich entscheiden musste
mehr ja immer mit afrikaner scharfer
tiere sowieso
ich bin jeden in der stadt verträgt sie
mit wissen oder so darum für mehr ist
auferstanden und verträglich früh sully
mit einer der anrufe lichterloh weniger
wird und mir jeder weniger aber die
große mehrheit dort daraufhin in der
mitte schwarze und dem krieg global sie
wenig gang sondern sie überhaupt lobt
das schwierige situation sie möchte ich
auch immer zur person des vcd und bitten
uns gläser wurde endlich von einer miss
militär wies im militär auf ist und ich
habe es innerhalb von stunden in sachen
packen und co
es ist das jahr 1990 alois graf ist 55
jahre alt
einer der jüngsten smb missionare in
simbabwe
graf ist unterwegs als seelsorger aber
ebenso als lebensretter
schon seit jahren gab es keine richtige
ernte mehr
doch dieses jahr ist die dürre besonders
schlimm die familien der kleinbauern
müssen hungern alois graf hat einen
bauern geld vorgestreckt damit dieser
einen maschendrahtzaun für einen
hühnerstall kaufen kann
denn bei seinen gottesdiensten versucht
alois graf priesternachwuchs anzuwerben
dennoch mir kommt keiner mehr aus europa
zu euch sagt er den menschen nur vielen
afrikanern erscheint das katholische
priester und wenig attraktiv wegen des
zölibats also viel hat die liegt das ist
ja die frau dem mann erhebliche ständig
auf die idee die die gesellschaft in der
bibliothek von 3 fand ihn die heute kaum
mehr benutzt wird auch nach 50 jahren in
afrika hat alois graf der bauernbub aus
dem napfgebiet seine herkunft nicht
vergessen
ich blutete und behält nur ob zu fuß
aufgewachsen auf diesem niveau nicht
glücklich jungen damit ihre ja mit
studium zusammen mit roter oder
studieren aber reichlich zäh henry dem
sich kagan europe kunden aber ganz klar
wieder zurück und ich möchte die in
afrika bliebe so lange aus mini
gesundheit erlaubt 1990
es ist bereits der sechzehnte staudamm
den pater sebi stocker in diesem jahr
baut er hat dazu eine kooperative
gegründet 80 männer haben so eine
bezahlte arbeit erhalten wäre nicht nur
vom himmel prediger und blüht auf der
himmel vertröste seine mentalität halfen
dass das gemacht wird was in es lagerten
macht abends schreibt der 70 jährige
missionar jeweils dankesbriefe an
hunderte von spendern in der heimat der
luzerner ist eine eigenwillige starke
persönlichkeit und musste einige
widerstände überwinden um diese
bauarbeiten anpacken zu können darf ich
staudammbau die zeit ganz 14 tage fehle
durch forscher schwinge und ist ist das
einfach dazu
das ist ja das gefasste wasser
ermöglicht dürrezeiten zu überleben
in der nähe eines staudammes hat eine
frauen kooperative einen großen
gemüsegarten angelegt
[Musik]
das ist liebe zu der frau war nicht an
bord sowie stocker stirbt 2005 in 53
staude mehr hat der insel bis zu seinem
tod gebaut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn die damen hand sie mir genau von
der rote zahlen wie die buchhaltung die
die gesunde sagte zahlen holen und von
dieter häberle megamind immer mehr
abstand vergrößert die felder und
natürlich der hände das sechs bis sieben
traktoren braucht für der ganze betrieb
doch heute ist der staudamm an
zahlreichen stellen undicht
auch ein termiten bau droht den erdball
zu zerstören
es könnte sie dass die moral gebrochen
wird wenn es genügend ungültig trainer
jung die steigungen nicht und das ist
die situation und wenn wir das nicht
wäre dort an einem erhöhten wie bisher
einfach kaputt ist
damit darf nicht verschwinden sie an ist
für sie aber die vergangene arbeit macht
dass der afrikaner versicherungs
geringste wird machen
nun muss gegen das gehört irgendwie zu
ihrer kultur dass man der frau die
mannschaft nicht wo frau wir sind im
feld frauenhandel irgendwie ordnet aber
man ruft auf der werft ihren sich für
ich übernehme von einer narbe die
trinken lieber bier aber sie betrachtet
sich als afrikaner ich ja natürlich ja
ja eigentlich als schweizerischen frick
haben wir werden nie afrika afrika nicht
worden
inwieweit ist schon burkhardt selbst zu
einem afrikaner geworden
das ist die identifikation oder dass man
in roth nicht so dass man wird mit ihnen
irgendwie freundschaft freundlich sie
und sie
sie schätzen ihre art und so das gehört
alles zum löschen
und wenn wir zusammen leben im alter wie
den alltag lässt daraus nehme viel mehr
erwartet sie sind ja selbst schon rang
drei und im schnitt zurück mit denen mit
denen dass sie sich mit schwarzem
abgeändert defizite schafft laufen für
das ein sehr schwaches freunde ich ja wo
ja oh ja
doch nicht alles ist kaputt gegangen in
der schreinerei wird das handwerk
welches die missionare hierher gebracht
haben weitergeführt
auch särge sind im angebot wo möchte
schon burkhard einst beerdigt werden
[Musik]
aber so schnell nein nein nein ich höre
tore und dazu natürlich auch noch dass
man wahrscheinlich dem gebet über filme
aus der heimat der heime nicht immer
sehen nicht über wunsch also eine
beerdigung
ja
[Musik]
früher fanden tuberkulose kranke heilung
im sanatorium der mission
heute sind die meisten patienten die
gabriel ihm steckt röstet aids-kranke
die böses ruhiger wird allerdings nicht
beim namen genannt
zu groß ist die scham für den walliser
missionar spielt das ohnehin keine rolle
denn er liebt diese menschen so oder so
[Musik]
das ist ganz wörtlich bzw
nun wird nur freundlich sie um es noch
nicht aber ich bin überlege als europäer
wenn du gehst benzin fassung entweder
fehler macht gewinnt die das ist viel ab
jeder mal kirchentags nicht europäer
e-books hingeguckt hat und das gesagte
sympathie zu afrika weil die würde alles
machen für mich ganz sicher
es ist der tag der abreise für ernst wie
sie war es kein einfacher besuch bei
seinen mitbrüdern in afrika
[Musik]
nach sony
eröffnen und ich hoffe dass ich dass ich
sie und jetzt kommt die phase von
loslösen der leitungen ständig mit dem
gedanken tragen
wie gut dass mit dem ziel lang und es
ist eigentlich
[Musik]
luzern im kanton luzern hinten in einem
natal gelegen
[Musik]
alois graf der missionar aus afrika ist
auf heimatbesuch
[Musik]
in lautern hat dass priester wort
gewicht
jedenfalls war das noch 1972 der fall
als alois graf auf einem urlaub in
dieser kirche für die waffen aus vor
verbots initiative war denn er hatte
selbst erlebt was auch schweizer waffen
in afrika anrichten konnten die wirkung
seiner predigt war eklatant lud
anstimmte als eine der wenigen luzerner
gemeinden für ein verbot des
waffenhandels mit dem kantonal höchsten
anteil
[Gelächter]
der grünen natürlich hoya gern mit
organen wie die teilnehmer aber vom
klima her bin ich jetzt mehrere so
könnte in afrika dass ich also hat mühe
da mit dem klima frauen der winter hatte
die nato zum anderen schweizer immer
spitz dass er ganz sicher freundliche
aufnahme typ aber die
fremdenfeindlichkeit und die schwächsten
vor allem durch ländliche gartenkunst
soll es mit augen jeder so jugendlich
den eigentlichen afrikaner überhaupt
kreta oder mit sammer rosé oder so ich
mag mich mini familie berührt
gallen zum test jetzt eigentlich mit
meiner afrikaner kräfte und sei aber
aber so dass ich da so mehrere
beschäftigen alois graf 81 jahre alt
seit 1965 missionar in afrika heute in
mosambik 300 kilometer von der nächsten
poststelle entfernt wie blickt da von
hier aus der reichen funktionierenden
schweiz auf afrika diesen kontinent den
viele als verloren betrachten
findigen uns mit uns selbst eine
landwirtschaft denn das riesige
potenzial wo sich natürlich auch endlich
ich glaube jung ist glauben afrika
entwickeln entwickeln sind die schweizer
ja sowieso ins durch entdeckten fehler
das sollte doch gefördert wenn sie da
schätzt dass pro liter
ganz hinten im tal liegt luthern bad das
nach einer wundersamen heilung vor 500
jahren zu einem wallfahrtsort wurde ein
tief katholisches land und so kann es
nicht erstaunen dass aus dem kleinen
luther gleich vier männer als immer sehr
missionare in die fremde zogen sagen die
straße ja ja recht gegeben der aber da
ist ja der andere
mentalitätsmäßig sei heute mehr
afrikaner als schweizer sagt alois graf
und doch ist er dieser landschaft und
ihren menschen verbunden geblieben
licht und schatten wechseln schnell in
diesem zerfurchten land und den
missionar zieht es in die höhe
[Musik]
und dass ich dir an sie heran sie den
check und das stachelige flur der
handbremse
denn die lange tour bist dir hören sie
flur wie eine liebeserklärung kleine
dieser hügel und flurnamen aus dem munde
des auswanderers in der nähe ist alois
aufgewachsen auf der horster eck wo die
mutter aus der wolle der schafe pullover
für die sieben kinder gestrickt hatte
dass der bergbauernhof heute nicht mehr
der familie gehört schmerzt den
heimkehrer aus afrika sehr
[Musik]
alle jahre im dezember heißt ernst will
die der generaloberer der immer sehr
nach rudolfstetten wo er vor 74 jahren
zur welt kam
es ist weihnachtsmarkt
[Musik]
ob schon ernst will die nicht mehr als
missionar in sambia tätig ist haben
freunde und bekannte auch dieses jahr
wieder einen stand eingerichtet um geld
zu sammeln für das dortige aids hospiz
wie nachzusehen 2013 nach seiner wahl
zum generaloberer hat ernst will die das
sterbehospiz verlassen müssen
[Musik]
die große mehrzahl beschädigungen und
der alte sowjetische braucht's gehabt
richtigen prioritäten zur schiitischen
bereits merken auf hochs zu man mit ihm
betrogenen maßnahmen unter der hand noch
erzählen wir den ganzen o2 verdacht
minister hahn einmal über ihren gekriegt
aber weiß winterschäden monate benötigen
natürlich einer journalistin der
lokalzeitung erzählt ernst willi aus
seinem leben
robin hood und
ein schicksal der familie will der vater
gestorben ist
und so musste sich der junge ernst das
geld für sein studium zusammen bett
2001 ernst will die aus dem magischen
rudolfstetten lebt in einer welt die von
einer biblischen plage verwüstet scheint
sambia vor 15 jahren ein land des
massenhaften sterbens aids hat sich im
südlichen afrika zu einer unerlässlichen
katastrophe entwickelt fast ein drittel
der menschen ist hiv positiv die
lebenserwartung ist von 62 auf 37 jahre
gesunken
im armenviertel von kalinka linker leben
die menschen in einem teufelskreis von
krankheit unwissenheit und arme müssen
sie aber hiv und kate hätte so
dramatisch zurück lautet litauen metro
vorbereitet so dass man jetzt die
situation hat das braucht sich krey
familie unberührtes da sahen wir mit 1,5
millionen aids-waisen die spitze stocker
der vorderleute und ich glaube es
erwartet dramatisch zu knapp vorbei also
man kann sagen das ist also
apokalyptischen in der plastiktüte einer
schweizer parfümerie trägt ernst will
die bibel gebetsbuch und die utensilien
für die letzte ölung mit sich
der zweit einer pflanze von der heilung
erwartet wird bei einer krankheit gegen
die doch kein kraut gewachsen ist
es ist eine erschütternde hilflosigkeit
die ernst willi bei seinen täglichen
besuchen antrifft die frau für den
priester zu ihrer tochter katrin war 24
jahre alt sie hat überall am körper
offene wunden
ihr mann ist gestorben jetzt lebt sie
bei ihrer mutter die beiden frauen
müssen sich alleine durchschlagen
und sie sorgen zudem für die kinder
einer verstorbenen schwester situation
das sind mehrere vor dem werkstor und
andere sind vor der frau einen weggang
rennst du mich krank werde oder wenn
damals groß welt und sieht große
verantwortlich seite überholt den harz
ist abrufdienst zeit um den blieb der
frau zurück
einige klinzing gestorben und ihr seid
die frau wo sie chance zu zeigen dass
campos ist komisch sagt dass sie treten
kann
der schächte könig jeden tag wenn ich es
selten zuvor war wie die lehrer am
priesterseminar von sambia
doch dann hat er sich entschlossen in
der zweiten hälfte seines lebens zu den
ärmsten der armen zu ziehen
jetzt lebt er in diesem kleinen zimmer
ohne jeglichen luxus doch manchmal so
sagt er sei ja sehr einsam in seiner
selbstgewählten mission also bis zum
brühl und sehen nicht geschlagen und der
wenig erleiden ich hatte also keine
promo nicht gehen das kann ich die
richtlinie kampagne clean room und der
ich mich sehr auf das lockt das lag ich
darüber warum meinst du solide und sind
zum teil so hilflos ausgeliefert
um den fühle ich mich eben auch hilflos
ich wirklich brauche ich kann aber die
mieter nicht an denn echte so sehr der
premiere hinter stimmte ernst willi hat
in der hauptstadt lusaka dieses
sterbehospiz mit aufgebaut
auch mit spendengeldern aus der schweiz
ladies hospiz heißt es ein schöner name
doch geheilt werden kann hier niemand
aids medikamente die den tod
hinauszögern könnten sind zu teuer
so spendet er seelsorger den sterbenden
trost und anteilnahme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eben ist eine frau im hospiz gestorben
[Musik]
das tägliche sterben
bamba ernst vater ernst wie sie ihn hier
nennen kann sich nicht daran gewöhnen
[Musik]
nun ist ernst will die zurückgekommen
nach sambia
zwei jahre nachdem er das sterbehospiz
schweren herzens verlassen musste um in
der schweiz die leitung der
missionsgesellschaft zu übernehmen und
man hat la bamba ernst nicht vergessen
[Musik]
es ist schön dich wiederzusehen
die jungen schön du aussiehst willi wer
hätte das gedacht das wird uns noch mal
auf dieser seite des himmels treffen als
ich dir gut bei sagte dachte ich dich
erst im himmel wiederzusehen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe danach mit der partie
für die sing und physischen zürich statt
wie die versionen von adobe
[Musik]
das spitalpersonal singt ein lied als
dank für eine nahrungsmittel spende die
eben eingetroffen ist
ohne spenden könnte das ladies hospiz
auch heute nicht weitergeführt werden
könnten die lebensverlängernden aids
medikamente nicht abgegeben werden wie
super alles halten ist und es läuft es
sind alles sagen wir 100 und sagen die
andere in der botschaft wie das geht
wissen wo beteiligen
und da steht auch noch das haus wo ernst
will die von der strengen lehre der
katholischen kirche abgewichen ist
als lehrer als aufklärer in den
schwierigen fragen der sexualität
ich habe ganz klar gemacht und sie waren
zum teil der seiten
so grüßte wenn frohsinn ich bin
katholische priester kann aber ganz klar
und deutlich gemacht es geht ihr defizit
nur eins mit total verwirrt ich vom tod
das sind kondoms aber händler steht in
widerspruch gegangen so katholisch doch
aber das hängt ein schild auf genau ich
begann
kritisiert wurde deswegen man sehen sie
doch nur für ratschläge hensel nicht
unbedingt viel praxis aber nein trophy
geht wenn jetzt beruhigen denn können
die infektion wie die infektion
verführte und ich länger und häufiger
sexualität dafür aber aber sie hat es ja
zur closed aber gemacht hat sie seien
das nicht sie sich die sind ja kondoms
verteilt oder von der regierung aber das
hat nicht gebraucht zu sagen will
neben dem hospiz befindet sich ein heim
für behinderte kinder die ohne die
betreuung durch schwestern sich selbst
überlassen wären hier her ist ernst will
die besonders gerne zurück gekehrt am
bau wird euch nun zeigen wie man sich
bewegt er wird mit euch tanzen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in sambia trifft er immer sehr auch das
befreundete ehepaar cherry cherry ist
agronom und entwicklungshelfer das paar
aus obwalden hat hier eine berufsschule
saniert 800 solche sind in sambia als
entwicklungsprojekt eröffnet worden
nur 290 davon sind noch in betrieb
warum läuft in der entwicklungshilfe so
viel falsch oft verschwinde halt einfach
das geld sagt uli der spende schnell
zeigen was man dem trainer machen
mitunter songs bogen das gebäude
zwischen b spielt dass man den schwung
das kann man schöne bilder zeigen aber
nachher wenn es darum geht die schulz
betriebe betriebsfeste guard und so das
ist es nicht mehr so attraktiv finden
und wenn nicht in organisation dahinter
oder den start der politisch wo das
gerät über das finanziert die das
relativ schnell wieder zurück
[Musik]
das hospiz ist eine grüne insel
getrennt durch eine mauer von der rauen
wirklichkeit kalinka linke heißt diese
eine staubige armen siedlung von lusaka
die nicht gerade den besten ruf genießt
ernst willi ist unterwegs mit einer
gemeindeschwester ohne begleitung wäre
ein solcher besuch für einen weißen
nicht ratsam
doch eigentlich ist sambia ein
friedliches land
und weil das binnenland mit seinen 15
millionen einwohnern in den letzten
jahren keine großen katastrophen für die
news in europa produziert hat ist es im
norden kaum bekannt doch stille kleine
katastrophen ereignen sich hier täglich
dieser mann ist krank hat starke
schmerzen im bauch was die ursache ist
als niemand sie handelt egal für
medizinische tests wenig passen auf dass
die augen wird womit frühjahr so kann
hand um die sagt heitz bekämpfen aber es
ist schwierig wenn sie allem feld
springt er tut es gut people to help you
this time of need die meisten menschen
von kalinka linga sind arbeitslos daran
vermag auch der rohstoffreichtum des
landes nichts zu ändern
bodenschätze die von ausländischen
unternehmen auch schweizerischen
ausgebeutet werden
[Musik]
reich ist das viertel hingegen an
kindern folgen auch einer
selbstverständlichen ungeschützten
sexualität mehrheit der märkte seit das
schönste geschenk gottes geht und mit
dem st wenn wir das benutzt das ist die
größte freude hat man anscheinend oder
sie ist alle sind gleich begabt wurde
mit dem st damit möglichst darauf hin
dass benutzer und dadurch die augen wo
ich das geld leider sind wir noch nicht
ganz weg
das den zug
alle ladies hospiz ist heute kein
ausschließliches sterbehospiz mehr hiv-
positive erhalten die aids medikamente
die den tod fernhalten
die bilder sind nicht mehr so grausam
wie damals als ernst will die hier beim
großen sterben half viele die heute in
den betten liegen werden wohl weiter
leben
und doch ist aids im südlichen afrika
eine gewaltige menschliche katastrophe
geblieben
mit den mitteln des priesters versucht
ernst will die ein wenig dagegen zu
halten
er hat so viele menschen sterben sie
wie schaut er dem eigenen tod entgegen
[Musik]
aber ich kann sich wie der große
gelassenheit kuriert dass ich das
einigen ausgelassenen kalkar nehmen wenn
wenn das auf mich suchen
aber es kann sehr gut sieht dass ich
nachher herausstellte
nikolos denn ich das aber mehr gewinn
sticht betrieb will alles was lebt wird
immer noch über hunger
die spenden franken aus der schweiz auch
jene aus rudolfstetten sind zusam
bisschen quatschen geworden prosaisch
dieses abschiedsgeschenk und doch ein
großer segen für jene die hier die
solche in sich tragen
wallis ein epizentrum des
schweizerischen katholizismus selbst ein
kleines dorf großes zur katholischen
sache beitragen kann leiden zb drei
missionare vier nonnen und zwei
schweizer gardisten entstammen aktuell
diesem ort im dorf restaurant geht
gerade eine trauerfeier zu ende und es
zeigt sich dass der geistliche nachwuchs
aus leiden in den letzten jahren
versiegt ist
denn der heutige dorfpfarrer müsste aus
polen geholt werden
gabriel in stück der missionar aus
simbabwe ist auf heimatbesuch hat
gabriel in stift denn die überlegt
heimzukehren
herr pater warum nicht hier bleiben als
sexy von grosser sankt bernhard und der
die schon fast hat man den zählt warum
nicht hier bleiben warum wieder gehen
der website der wird mal verschließen
obama macht der blick aber so nach lehne
paris
ich würde wirklich nicht wie so was
machen im altersheim besucht gabriel in
steps eine 94 jährige schwester und
hilda der mutter nennt weil sie ihn nach
dem frühen tod der leiblichen mutter
aufgezogen hatte begeistert was ich
nicht gerade damals als ihr bruder
verkündete er gehe nach afrika
der simplon 2000 meter über meer
gabriel ist mit seinem bruder peter noch
einmal auf dem berg zurückgekommen
hier hat er als kleiner bub im sommer
die parcours des vaters gehütet und hier
ist damit den missionaren erstmals in
kontakt gekommen
denn in diesem haus haben die priester
seminaristen aus immensee jeweils ihre
sommerferien verbracht so bin ich dann
dort in der gesellschaft und in afrika
war eine unbekannte welt und afrikaner
gab es damals kaum im wallis
die sind da sind menschen fressen
verlegt und aber nachher ist man doch
von pci verworren und hexe das ist
missionsland und dagegen helfe die
häuser in immensee sind in den letzten
jahren zu groß geworden
die mächtigen gebäude der
missionsgesellschaft bethlehem haben
sich geleert viele räume sind kaum mehr
genutzt
[Musik]
doch neue aktivitäten kündigen sich an
handwerker sind da es wird umgebaut
aus einem einstigen büroraum wird eine
küche zum frieden aus oberhausen sowie
[Musik]
vom kanton sie immer so stuft als
holzheim frauen das gebäude
naja in dieses gebäude sollen in einigen
wochen minderjährige asylbewerber
einziehen
der kanton schwyz die nöten es fehlt an
unterkünften für flüchtlinge der
gemeinschaft scs natürlich auktionen
dass das so viel angeben und das große
buffet gegeben und sind der küche an
strom gegenüber so viele freunde aber
mitte zieht ich eben ruhiger wurde und
sie fast wie die stadt mit denn das
interessante ist ja vieles vor einem
automaten in russland in der so genannte
mission und und jetzt mit ihr vor eine
andere vor der rede von ried und rapid
und findet ihren platz höchst durch doch
wunderbar befindet also große es auch
dass er so eine wann die idee die
geschichte ist so traurig dass für die
rechtlich aber dass mir doch egal als
heimat zeigen milch sind offen für die
hypo wo sie denn jetzt ganz so schlecht
der innenhof des gebäudekomplexes hier
werden die betagten männer in einigen
wochen auf die jungen asylbewerber
treffen
heute ist das eine versteckte stille
oase gesäumt von werken des kunstmalers
und priesters pablo meyer
es wäre schön wenn ich ein
schwarzafrikaner wer in der mail an
denen würde ich auch die flucht gar ich
begriff gilt absolut wie schwierig das
wird auch für russen wenn wir dort 50
jugendliche hand parierte vor über 40
jahren in rhodesien mit einer zeichnung
eine ernsthafte krise zwischen der
weißen regierung und der
missionsgesellschaft verursacht eine
weiße hand erdrückt schwarze menschen
diese karikatur erschien als titelblatt
einer immer sehr publikation in
rhodesien und das ist natürlich rasche
mali dem ruf sie wenn die kritik für die
wärme xs stop für die roosters hand aber
was haben wir christen dafür einen
triumph gab das genau ist sie und freute
sich tiere davon erfüllen
der immense missionar und tritt welt
journalisten trat war als redaktor
verantwortlich für den abdruck der
karikatur weshalb auch er von der weißen
regierung rhodesien des landes verwiesen
wurde
habe war ein international renommierter
publizist groß deshalb das aufsehen als
er im märz 1970 rhodesien verlassen
musste viel reichtum hat sich am
zugersee dies im innerschweizer tief
steuer land versammelt auch die
missionare hocken auf einem schatz auf
einen immobilien schatz und darauf soll
in zwei drei jahren eine grosse
überbauung mit insgesamt 150 wohnungen
entstehen wohnen in bethlehem heißt das
vorhaben dass die missionare nicht für
millionäre bauen möchten sondern mit
bezahlbaren wohnungen eine wenige
exklusive mieterschaft ansprechen wollen
hat ihnen auch kritik eingetragen und
wieland sich das woche wenn wenn also
thürig und die alten tiefs und metro
dann auf so für die gottes mir herrn
bislang im dienst ums kaufen oder futter
richtig gut ich beide normen zu finden
auf der suche nach einem besseren leben
sind diese jungen menschen in immensee
angekommen
an einem regnerischen tag im august
zieht die erste gruppe minderjährige
asylbewerber bei den missionaren 1
die meisten stammen aus afghanistan und
eritrea aber auch aus syrien und somalia
betreut werden sie von mitarbeitern der
caritas
[Applaus]
ich heiße frau anna maria ja also das
einkommen aus zu lernen und ich bin 45
10 jahre reisen kann aus afghanistan und
jetzt ich bin elf woher nehmen sie es
sind kinder noch einige wurden von
verzweifelten eltern allein auf die
ungewisse reise geschickt andere haben
auf der flucht ihre familien verloren so
ihre option gehört mein name ist ernst
ein großes thema in der letzten zeit war
wie können wir jungen männern und frauen
allen zuhause anbieten
wir haben nämlich hier leere zimmer
wir sind überglücklich dass es uns
gelungen ist einzuladen und ihr seid ihr
da insgesamt 45 minderjährige
asylbewerber werden in immensee erwartet
die jüngeren unter ihnen sollen die
gemeinde schule in küssnacht besuchen
die älteren werden hier im haus
unterrichtet
zwei jahre werden sie hier leben können
dann müssen sie dem neubauvorhaben
weichen
masala es ist eine ironie dieser
geschichte
einst zogen die missionare von hier aus
in die dritte welt heute kommen die
unglücklichen aus dem süden zu ihnen an
den zugersee toten vogel so nennen
einige mitbrüder mit schwarzem humor
ernst wilde den vormaligen
sterbebegleiter aus sambia und schon
wieder muss der generalobere eine
beerdigung organisieren
über manche nachruf könnte will die den
titel setzen
von den schwierigkeiten gutes zu tun
ich tröste wo ruhig sind jetzt jemand
sagt johannes lang bauten schaffe
durchgemacht und jetzt geht als alles zu
haben und deswegen sieht rüdiger und so
weiter denn ich habe mir diese zusage
aber auch tief in deren haus in afrika
asien lateinamerika wo immer das klima
und die erträge der besitzer vor dem und
das hat echt glücklich mache ich eine
menge zeit wo am stellberg es ist alles
gut es ist doch wunderbar durch so viel
schöner machen
[Musik]
gabriel in stoff ist nur noch wenige
tage in der schweiz
womöglich war dies sein letzter heimat
urlaub was ist größer der schmerz beim
abschied oder die freude afrika wieder
zu sehen wenn es darauf an ob das trio
40 grad am nachmittag ob 0 und das
schweizer nur wände reduziert um den es
nur eines drauf und nach mehr staat im
busch mit liter zürcher besteht der
hämmer und den heißt überall her sind
wir dann da aber er sieht wieder da
bricht er wir sind wieder da nicht hier
sondern in afrika will gabriel in stoff
begraben werden und ein schönes lautes
fest soll es geben
da sind sicher diese oder wenn ich würde
dann für zwei dieser warte oder und
diesen chor sing und betten für die
jahrzehntelang schafft es ist es fast
wir feiern das leben eines menschen
nicht traurig über seinen tod
wir feiern sein leben das ist ein wunder
hört er ist druck und auswerten was sich
in afrika
ja das eigens stellen alles gehört dann
wurden immer verbergen und ein alter
schlechter macht dann geht es nur dann
wenn wir heiliggesprochen täter ans
luzern
er will ihr alle die ihr auf aris
vorausgegangen sei betet für uns und das
wiedersehen
da geht das fest wir in afrika druck das
leben gefeiert wird nicht der tod
betrauerte
amen amen amen
[Musik]